so this is one of those occasions where
at least peaceful nationalism could
really be a good thing for all of us
to help keep us from this agenda to help
protect us from this agenda
a lot of the globalists today's
globalists who are pushing the globalist
agenda very actively
uh are i believe also involved
in satanism and satanist abuse
so we we need to be wary about what the
big picture is
on on all this um and
to okay i know he's unpopular with some
or maybe many americans but at least
trump is
is very right to oppose
globalism and that in itself
is a big obstacle to the satanists
because obviously the usa is the only
superpower left
in the world and if they are opposed to
globalism
then uh well trump has to be removed
that's their view and
replaced with somebody who will sign the
u.s
up to the globalist agenda
and of course that will eventually lead
to
the global government becoming more and
more powerful
we've seen something like this in europe
with the eu the european union
that's nation signed up to the eu
initially thinking it was mainly about
economics
but as time went by they were
giving up more and more of their
national
powers and discretion
to the eu and the eu has never been a
very transparent and accountable
body and so
now they're talking about the eu
becoming a
uh like a united states of america
united states of europe
and having this um much more powerful
government over the eu than was
originally
considered when it first started so
at least in the uk there were a lot of
people saying that
this is not we signed up what we signed
up for
you know we've been led down this road
where we we've had our
our national discretion and
discretionary powers and freedoms
chipped away and fortunately the uk
did vote for brexit and did eventually
get brexit
despite all the the fight that the eu
gave the uk government on this
the eu has a strong vested interest in
seeing the uk
fail economically because
if the uk fails other countries will
be much less likely to dare to leave the
eu
because they will say well look uk tried
to go on its own
and survive economically outside the eu
and it failed
so we must stay in the eu at least for
economic
prosperity and security and
uh this is another part of the big
picture
uh because this new world order
one of the key components is the
european union
and the european union as a model for
eventual
world government so who
are these politicians that you spoke of
earlier in the uk
or around the world for that matter that
you're aware of that are
pushing globalism or talking about it
seriously
and are are people taking these guys
serious
and is there any substance to
what they're talking about and what
they're pushing as far as globalism
i think the
global the globalism has a lot of
support from
various uk politicians including some
very senior ones so for example
uh the politician who called for the
setting up of one world government to
deal with the
pandemic the pandemic for example
uh that was gordon brown the former uk
prime minister and
that lends a lot of impact to the
statement because he's a former
prime minister of the uk
the other politicians who have been
supporting this
kind of approach are
generally on the left of
the political spectrum so
you will find for example when britain
was trying to implement brexit
there was a lot of opposition from the
left
because they are more in favor of the
european union
and they would uh
try to if not
stop brexit from happening and
interesting to bear in mind tony blair
the labor
prime minister former labor prime
minister of the of the uk was actually
saying
at one point just ignore the referendum
vote
ignore the majority vote of the uk
people
and keep the uk and the eu against the
will of the majority
that was his uh opinion at one point
that he expressed
about how to deal with the referendum
result
that's how desperate some of the left
leaning politicians
were to keep the uk uh
in the eu and of course tony blair has
always been
a very active globalist
so i suspect you have the same
attitudes in the usa with more
politicians on the left wanting the u.s
to go down the globalist road than those
on the right
of the political spectrum the
the fact is this is the new world order
that we've been talking about
a one world government a globalist uh
political remaking of of world politics
and at the top of the pyramid ruling
over all this
will be the satanist uh so-called
savior who christians refer to as the
antichrist
and then all the
all controlling micromanaging rules
will come in on all of us
having to be micromanaged by this one
world government
we're already going in the general
direction of micromanagement you would
have noticed it especially with the
pandemic
uh suddenly we're being told what
distance we have to keep from others
when we have to wear a face mask
uh we can't assemble in more than a
certain
number of people i've noticed a lot more
interest in sra
since the pandemic started and the
restrictions were implemented
because people suddenly realize how
fragile their freedoms are
how it can just go like that right and
in the uk
we've spent months in lockdown
similar to house arrest you could say
and with very little political debate
just basically parliament rubber
stamping all these restrictions
for our own good inverted commerce
the numbers are questionable i do not
know
about where you are but in the uk there
have been questions about
the numbers of actual deaths from
covet 19 because there's suspicion that
a lot of these numbers are inflated i'm
not saying there's no covet 19 i'm
saying that
uh a much smaller number of copy 19
cases have occurred but they're being
amplified
uh exaggerated
in order to achieve a certain political
agenda so for example
their weapons they're weaponizing it to
their own agenda
the concerns that for example there are
people
who died with covet 19 present in their
bodies but
not from kobe 19 killing them being
added to the statistics
right because they all jack up the
numbers
right right right and then in the u.s
hospitals that do that they they
actually receive
more money from the government when
their patients are dying of covid so you
know if they had code and they died of a
heart attack
you know they get paid something in the
realm of 30 grand for a covet death
versus like
five to ten thousand dollars for a heart
attack so that encourages
exaggerating the numbers and another
uh source of questioning is
a reliable contact of mine going to look
at some of the hospitals which were
supposed to be
full of covet 19 patients and seeing
that the hospitals were practically
empty
doesn't match the rhetoric right that's
being reported what's
on the ground you'd expect the hospitals
to be flooded
with patients and
at least the hospitals that my contact
went to visit and look at
and because he was questioning what was
being claimed by the government
were empty he even told me that some of
the medical staff were just
like sending text messages looking at
their mobile phones
not not terribly busy
so it just adds to the
suspicion that the numbers are being
grossly exaggerated for a political
agenda which is
to justify more restrictions more
control more micromanagement
more calls for one world government to
deal with this
huge invented commerce problem uh
and and i think we we need to
to be looking below the surface
questioning these things investigating
going to hospitals where
you'd expect if there were really this
larger number of patients
that the patients would be at those
hospitals and seeing how crowded they
are
and how many of the patients they are
actually suffering from copper 19 or
from other illnesses